the numbers of votes cast for each
candidate is as follows uh mordent
one zero five
sunak one three seven
truss one one three
therefore rishi sunak and liz trust will
be the candidates going forward to a
final ballast of conservative party
members
the ballot will close on the 2nd of
september and i will announce the
results at 12 30 p.m on monday the 5th
of september thank you very much
well there it is the result it was going
to be rishi sunak and liz truss who will
go through to the final stage of the
contest the two candidates and tory
party members are now going to vote on
who to be the next prime minister and
leader of their party rishi sunak
topping that poll with 137 votes liz
truss on 113 penny mordents on 105 which
means she is now eliminated well let's
go straight to our political editor beth
wrigley shall we for some analysis beth
what do you make of those results
well i'm just looking at the figures
there and in terms of the final round
there really was a consolidation of
votes with liz trust the one
putting on the most votes there plus 27
from the final round it is a sonic
versus truss run off it is if you like
the battle of ideas for the direction of
the conservative party is it more of
trying to cut inflation and then cut
taxes or is it a more blue-blooded liz
trust deregulatory pitch in which she
begins to cut taxes now a real battle
for ideas between these two candidates
and as for penny mordant well she was
eight short of liz trust such a tight
race if just four mps had changed their
minds the votes could have fallen a
different way she put on 13 from the
last ballot she will no doubt be
absolutely devastated she led didn't she
up to this round and liz trust overtaken
her there but in terms of the wider
party for rishi sunak i think this is a
more difficult contender for him in that
liz truss is the foreign secretary she
too has cabinet experience and she will
give a different version of conservatism
tarishi sunak crucially as well for liz
tras she was the one that
did not uh leave cabinet did she did not
resign she stayed loyal to boris johnson
now that might have been uncomfortable
for her
in the hours when dozens of colleagues
were leaving government but in terms of
the party membership many of whom
are still big fans of boris johnson it
will help her so i think in terms of
that too
rishi sunak is going to have a hard
battle against liz trust in terms of
winning over party members what did
rishi sanat want to do well look at the
figures how far ahead of it is i'll try
and do this quickly in my head he's 30
something votes 34
votes ahead of liz truss now in terms of
that he wanted to put clear blue water
between her and himself in order to try
and portray to party members
that he
was really the part the choice of mps
and that he really will be the more
competent candidate but look it's the
foreign secretary versus the former
chancellor it's going to be a very very
very punchy race and i imagine that
there's going to be a lot of attacks
over the weekend and i would also
imagine that there will be more dirty
tricks in this runoff and it could be
quite unpleasant yet with lots of rumors
swirling around about dark arts and
attack jobs and each of the candidates